Hey youtubers it's Charlie and since so much
has been happening with Walking Dead this
summer I thought it was time to do a bonus
video. They've been filming for several weeks
now so we've got a pretty good look at some
of the new people and the cast have been doing
a lot of interviews teasing season 5 stuff.
So I'm going to explain who those new characters
are, there are a bunch of them. And some of
the big plot rumors.
Hello any new people who are just finding
me for the first time. I'm going to be doing
more bonus videos now that they're filming
the new season. Be sure to subscribe to get
everything. Feel free to grab some barbecue
off the grill. Just don't ask where we got
the meat.
So starting off with new characters. Last
week Seth Gilliam was seen on set dressed
as a priest. So I think it's safe to say he's
playing Father Gabriel from the comics. He
was announced a long time ago and he fit the
description of that character, but now that
he's been spotted.
The infamous car that yoinked Beth was also
spotted on the set recently. The only with
the cross on the back. The first time we saw
it theories were everywhere between Hunters,
Saviors and Father Gabriel.
The show changes a lot of things from the
comic, so whenever Beth got kidnapped it seemed
a lot like the Dale Hunters plot from the
comics. Even though we've learned to not trust
new people, I don't think Gabriel is a bad
person but careful for spoilers for his backstory
from the comics real quick. If you want to
know just skip forward in the video like 25
seconds.
Gabriel had a church before the outbreak where
he was pretty normal. After shit hit the fan
everyone in the area started to come to him
for food and protection but because there
were so many he turned them all away. He was
afraid of running out of food and supplies.
That's his tragic backstory, he's haunted
by that failure. So it's possible that he's
trying to save Beth to make up for that.
There's been no indication that he's going
to be a Terminus character at the start of
the season. Supposedly he took Beth and went
somewhere else, either Alexandria or more
likely his church. The place where Beth and
Daryl were at seemed more like a funeral parlor
than Gabriel's church from the comics.
There is a picture someone took of a church
at a different location that could be the
church he'll have on the show but there's
been no indication how far it will be from
Terminus.
Just for reference here is Terminus on an
actual map, it's in Macon Georgia. Just to
give you an idea where the main characters
are. That's not where they film it, that's
just where they are in the show. The Terminus
scenes were shot near the place in Atlanta,
Georgia where the pilot for the series was
shot.
Aside from confirmed Father Gabriel the other
big new character is named Burton. E News
revealed the character description. He's a
teenager, think like Beth's age, and he's
going to be one of the other captives at Terminus.
He wasn't part of the original Prison group,
so he's someone they run into while they're
there.
The character trait that's being teased is
that he only has one leg. No details yet on
whether he lost it before he arrived at Terminus
or after. As in, he lost it to the barbecue
grill.
It sounds like what they're doing is giving
part of Dale's story with the Hunters to Burton.
In the comics, before Dale died he was bitten
by Walkers, then captured by the Hunters.
They ate one of his legs before he was rescued
by Rick and the survivors.
Supposedly Burton is going to spend a lot
of time with the Bob Stookey character.
There were a couple new teenage characters
in Season 4 like Patrick and Zack, they turned
out to be red shirts and died pretty quickly.
So we don't really know if that's what's going
to happen to Burton or if he's going to be
a much bigger part of the story.
One of the big running themes with the main
characters is finding a reason to keep fighting.
I think that the major arc of season 5 is
going to be escaping Terminus and the cannibals.
Then Season 6 is going to be the road to Alexandria
and Season 7 will be full on Negan.
I already did a Negan video because supposedly
he's going to make a minor appearance in Season
5. Scott Gimple and Robert Kirkman have talked
about him being on the show a lot, but everything
they've said about him implies that he's not
going to be a main character yet. This is
where the Gareth character comes in.
Think of him as being a slightly different
version of the Chris character from the comics,
the leader of the Hunters. Gareth was upgraded
to cast regular for season 5, so he's going
to be in most of the episodes. No word on
whether he'll survive to season 6 but he's
not the new Governor.
If you watched Arrow this year at all, think
of him like Brother Blood. The medium bad
character who paves the way for the big bad
to come along eventually. In this case that
would be Negan, but Terminus isn't in the
comics, so the show probably won't introduce
Negan until they get closer to Alexandria.
The other major rumor that's going around
is that Maggy is going to be pregnant and
Glenn will end up dying. I have to talk about
the comics plot real quick, so skip forward
like 20 seconds if you don't want to know
about Glenn in the comics.
Glenn does die in the comics, but he's killed
by Negan who smashes the hell out of him with
Lucille, his bat. So if the show kills Glenn
at Terminus it would be a big change.
The rumor got started when Alanna Masterson
Tweeted this very ominous sounding message.
It was after a day where the set was on complete
lockdown and none of the cast memebers were
allowed to leave to go back to their trailers.
So whatever was happening was super secret.
And reportedly, Steven Yeun had spent that
week saying goodbyes to all the cast members.
It's not confirmation or anything, but it
does suggest that something extreme will happen
to Glenn.
One more time I have to talk about Maggie
in the comics, so skip forward in the video
about twenty seconds if you don't want to
hear it.
In the comics, Maggie tries to commit suicide
after falling into deep depression. Remember
how I said Season 5 is all about escaping
Terminus and finding a reason to keep fighting?
Supposedly Maggie is going to contemplate
suicide after Glenn's supposed death but it's
her pregnancy, Glenn's unborn baby, that gives
her the will to keep living.
Speaking of babies, Carol and Tyreese still
have Judith and they're not at Terminus...yet.
They get there eventually because Norman Reedus
was talking about Daryl Dixon Carol shipping.
In the comics they had a thing, but the show
hasn't done that yet. So eventually we'll
get to see a lot of them together this season.
Norman Reedus said that Daryl sees a lot of
himself in her.
Don't expect and hardcore sex scenes, but
it sounds like the show is slowly heading
in that direction.
Once some this processes, let me know what
you think about the idea of Maggie being pregnant,
Father Gabriel and maybe Glenn dying.
I think right now the thing I'm most looking
forward to is seeing the first trailer. Which
is actually what my next video is going to
be. Or at least it's going to be about the
special marathon where they're going to debut
new footage.
AMC and Talking Dead are going to show off
some Season 5 footage on Sunday July 6th.
They're doing a Fourth of July weekend Walking
Dead Marathon where they just air the who
series from season 1 to 4 back to back.
Be sure to subscribe to get my video. I'll
be doing a full breakdown of the new footage.
I'm going to do some more bonus videos before
that, but I'm really excited to see some actual
footage.
Right now click here to learn about Negan
in Season 5 and click here for some of my
Season 5 predictions.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!